what's going on everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder and
today we have some new
spider-man no way home leaks including a
very
very good look at spider-man's new black
and gold
suit and we also have a better look at
zombie hunter spider-man that is going
to be appearing in marvel's what if
and now marvel and sony have started
advertising doctor strange
with some of the packaging for
spider-man no way home
still no trailer but a lot of toys
rolling out then we have a toy leak that
seemingly confirms
a plot leak that we've talked about
before on the channel so let's dive into
these new spider-man details and if
you're new be sure to subscribe and hit
that notification bell so you don't miss
out on any of the latest spider-man
videos or
mcu videos so we have two new suits to
kind of look at for spider-man no way
home and first let's start with the
black and gold suit
now i've been hearing a lot of mixed
opinions about this suit some people
think it's awesome and some people don't
like it very much but we know that
spider-man is going to be getting at
least
two new suits in the movie and i'm
talking about both in this video but
this one is most likely coming from
tony stark's technology it actually
looked like in spider-man far from home
that this black and gold suit was
loaded into the software for making a
new suit that peter parker used in far
from home where he made
his black and red suit so this is most
likely from happy because we do know
that he is going to be in the film
yeah i need a suit suit
now based off of everything that we've
heard so far this is just going to be a
normal spider-man suit
it may be a tiny bit more heavy-duty
than his black and red suit but seen as
it's probably made from the same machine
i'm guessing that it's just a new suit
because his black and red one gets
roughed up a little bit
however we've had many leaks at this
point talking about
an integrated suit funko pop leaks have
called it the integrated suit
other toy leaks as well and some plot
leaks talked about it too
and today we have another leak
confirming this integrated suit on the
back of this toy box it reads
spider-man gears up in his iron spider
integration
suit to fight evil and defeat villains
everywhere now if you notice those
web blasters that he's shooting are gold
and that's because this
integrated suit is integrated with magic
from what we know it's the iron spider
suit that doctor strange gives magic to
now the integrated suit has also been in
a plot leak that i've been told is true
doctor strange does give spider-man some
magical abilities and no way home
which is going to be pretty cool to see
so this integrated suit is probably
going to be one of the highlights of
spider-man no way home hopefully it's
not too underwhelming but actually
does some pretty cool things obviously
with the multiverse spiderverse and
so many villains coming after spider-man
he's going to need some help
now we know that he's going to be
getting some help from toby maguire
spider-man and
andrew garfield spider-man but they're
not going to come into the film until
about halfway into the movie and before
then he's definitely going to be dealing
with some villains by himself so he's
going to be needing some help
and that's where doctor strange comes in
and as you can see in this leak there is
some packaging for some toys about to
roll out that
actually shows doctor strange and this
is kind of interesting because it's also
showing things from spider-man
homecoming and far from home
but of course doctor strange has been in
neither of those films and is going to
be in no way home for those of you who
are thinking that doctor strange might
have a minor role it looks like he's
actually going to have a pretty big role
the multiverse is involved which is his
area of expertise and what he's going to
have to deal with so he's going to
really be helping out peter parker in
this film
and it looks like a lot of the toys and
merchandise coming out is going to show
that
now last but not least not related to
spider-man no way home but spider-man
related nonetheless for marvel's what if
we have a leak of zombie hunter spidey
with this marvel legends figure that is
coming out we get a much better
look of him wearing the cloak of
levitation which of course is doctor
strange's but
not in what if at least not in this
episode now this
is confirmed to be zombie hunter spidey
we've learned this before and this just
further makes it official
and the description we have on the back
reads as follows
zombie hunter spider-man is a ragtag
group of survivors
fighting his way through a zombie
infested world
this is a little bit different than what
we thought the zombie episode was going
to be we thought it was just going to be
bucky dealing with the zombies because
that's all we've seen so far
but this confirms that spider-man is
actually going to be a pretty big part
in that episode and it looks like he
could be pretty magical
which could be pretty cool to see and
hopefully it's something we're about to
see in spiderman no way home
but we'll have to wait and see on that
but in the meantime let me know what you
think about these leaks in the comments
down below
and no unfortunately i have not heard
anything new about the spiderman no way
home trailer but the venom trailer is
supposed to drop on monday and that's
according to daniel rbk the full
venom let there be carnage trailer so be
sure to subscribe and hit that
notification bell so you don't miss out
on my breakdown for that trailer
don't forget to like this video and for
live updates you can always follow me on
instagram and twitter
and as always thank you all so much for
watching woof